what I could consider a dramatic sin and
acting is st CD which is stuttering to
create drama once I tell you what it is
you're gonna see it everywhere if you
ever come near my family I swear if you
ever ever come near my fit you know you
stutter to create drama and I hate it
hi I'm M night Shyamalan the director of
my new movie glass and I'm here to break
down one of the scenes in the movie do
you even know what that means no it's
actually a really fun scene very pivotal
one and up to this point they've all
been in their individual rooms in this
institution and mr. glass has found a
way to get into the wards room what you
need to know about that room it has a
hypnosis light and there's a camera and
every time a threatening identity comes
it's trove and forces him to switch to
another identity so mr. glass is
dismantling that so he can get the Horde
out of their room alright we're gonna
stop there this is a Steadicam I don't
use it much in this movie because it has
a particular quality kind of a floaty
kind of unnatural quality but for this
moment almost a kind of a surreal moment
we decided to use the Steadicam and just
spin around the characters as he's
dismantling this life and the first
character you see when you walk in is
Patricia and she's waiting for him she's
been waiting for mr. glass to get their
mouth so that's who just sat up from
that chair
[Music]
what's up Patricia told us you were
coming
my name is Luke 19 bored all the way so
Luke is one of the editors on the movie
and he has a bad reputation for telling
you the ending of movies so when we're
at lunch whenever he says oh I saw that
movie
he'll inevitably start with all see
stop-stop-stop-stop-stop anis gets angry
at us you know what what I'm not gonna
say anything I'm not gonna say
everything and then he'll say something
like everybody knows everybody knows
Bruce dies at the hands of the Exorcist
and we'll all just scream at him and he
gets angry and storms off he'll be very
angry I told you this sue blaim do you
even know what that means
know that that term the American sublime
inque my love painting and in the museum
there's this in Philadelphia there's an
area of painting called the Americans
sublime where there's a lot of storms in
the distance in all of the paintings and
there and I said what is that and that
was kind of the portentous the sense of
war coming towards them and then you saw
in that scene there as we passed it be
passed at 24 to that are in there which
is an illusion all those personalities
and you also see that in in split there
that is why this world is a lost cause
that is why the beast is the only thing
that is pure and meaningful American
sublime refers to western paintings of
landscapes and seascapes depicting the
immensity of nature the use of violent
storms in the distance was a common
practice paintings is a particularly
interesting
and when we were in rehearsal this is a
funny thing and Sam did that for the
first time he did it like a kid it was
so cute he was like pretending the under
the lights and then he goes painting is
a particular interest to me and he like
flicked his eyebrows was so fun he we
didn't end up getting to do that but
whenever I see this scene I think of him
and rehearsals being a little kid this
is Hedwig and everyone loves Hedwig
but now it's closed now it's open you
might be pregnant now James plays twenty
personalities in the movie half of them
are with the Horde meaning with the bad
guys and half of them are not so you're
meeting a bunch of the characters that
are with with the bad guys James is
theater trained and film trained so
doing long takes really committing is in
his blood
you know his technique is amazing your
your mind what's my
you're nine we have it right yeah so
this is a an example of blocking that I
think is the lost art for me we tend to
do it like TV a lot which is there's
there's cameras that are static and the
actors are just blocked and they in a
very static way and we don't really
think about the way old filmmakers used
to block they would say she comes
forward the camera meets you and then
moves over to here and then you see the
smoke the cigarette in the ashtray then
it moves to the thing and you really
block the camera and the actors so the
art of blocking is that Hedwig kneels
down and end up in this kind of
father-son profile here and then at the
end and I almost never let actors ad-lib
we treat it like a play you say what I
wrote but here I let them do a little
bit of what I couldn't consider a
dramatics in enacting which is st CD
which is stuttering to create drama if
you ever come near my family I swear if
you ever ever come near my family no you
stutter to create drama and I hate it
but I allowed them to do it here because
it played as characters challenging each
other yeah so I hope you enjoyed that
clip I hope you guys all go see glass
when it opens in theaters on January
18th and go buy your tickets on Fandango
[Music]
[Music]